question for you really so would you
like a fit spin-off would that be cool
because I think that'd be cool just
saying yeah well you're walking like
your thoughts on that ever it was like
ever it was like FETs in his monkey be
cool yeah I got a whole show based on
that just what they get up to and they
don't even do stuff I'm redoing the
monkeys as you want because that's
that's the same and people talk about
physics and yeah and like not even
anything happens like most of the
episodes are just the two of them sent
to yo watching TV that's funny yeah how
so yeah we should get campaigns like
that as long as I get a monkey like
kickstart I'll do it
alright thanks I suddenly had the feed
in the next piece of Marvel promo work
for series 3 will be Fitz and his monkey
sounds like a euphemism
will there be any appearances from any
heroes from the MCU and engine shield
well we get a few don't really like
we've had we've had people kind of crop
up here and there you talking about like
the Avengers I think that's what you're
after isn't it yes like Doctor Strange
oh well I'm keeping my fingers crossed
apparently um old Iron Man is said that
it's his favorite show and he wouldn't
like if he was going to do a cameo on
any of them it would be agents of shield
so I'm keeping my fingers crossed for
that I think it was like someone said
someone asked me on Twitter or something
he said agents of shield Robert Downey
jr. this is obviously not actually I'm
an no he's Robert daily he's Robert
daily ginger but Iron Man's real
after infinity Wars part - there's
scheduled in humans so with with the
Inhumans have been shown in Marvel's
agency
- that movie I really hate this because
whenever we get like ask questions are
doing if we can't ask these questions
and we don't know the answers and even
if we did we can tell you so but yeah I
mean it the honest answer is got no idea
got no idea what what they're planning
but I think it would be I think everyone
would be pretty excited if there was
that that crossover going the other way
as well so so fingers crossed well I'll
let you know as soon as I do awesome and
quickly for Ian harm
I know Enders see in the first series
you got injury we ever recover from that
um well I mean if I think he's come on I
think at the start of season two he was
definitely feeling the effects of that
of that injury and I think he's got a
lot better season two has gone on but I
think that stuff I think that the things
but that kind of injury always stays
with you it's just you become you never
kind of go back to who you were before
it's kind of a new different person that
you become did in coping with it
I got quite deep there also in fact a
lot thank you though hi guys I love you
um Susan if there was one moment in the
whole series that defines your character
what would it be and why good question
when I I think when FETs met Lance just
cemetary man it was it definitely a
spark there yeah yeah no one no one no
one's also asked about the Fitz and
hunters spin-off yet but we've been
working on Emily and I spare time yeah
do you want to sing think should he
sings a great thing - singing shut up
next year we'll work it out for next
year what was the question again the
moment it divided I like like defining
moment in the series I reckon it was
probably for Lance it was probably when
quite late on in the series when we're
in that little teka teka bar I walk in
and Coulson and I sign on I think that
was it 400 I think that was it when he
went yeah I'm I'm here to stay
so thanks oh yeah I'm just wondering now
that Skye's got superpowers
is there any superpowers you want for
your characters as well for like season
three I'd love some yeah I'm trying to
think what would be the best seekers is
the difference between superpowers I
would choose and what I would choose as
an actor in the show we'd have to be
something something didn't require too
much like stunt work like flight flying
sounds like fun but actually everyday
like hanging on strings in the air would
get quite tedious I reckon after a while
so I don't know is super bad be like
sitting having a beer what were you I
would like to look like bread Dalton for
a day
what no taste some people um I was just
wondering who's the biggest diva or
Joker on set we could get people in
trouble here I actually want to I can
see you're pretty difficult on you with
it Eaton's quite rude to the crew like
that's his thing
he's quite a Busey he gets so many
things when Nick came and he was like
people were like he's a bet is a bet d
verse but don't worry doesn't like he
comes in every morning and asked for
like 20 peeled grapes like any
straightest normal huh yeah things like
that I'm going time to Peter must see uh
I'd say like Ming now when she's not
diva but she's crazy bonhomie she's
clinically insane yeah it's not funny
she's kind of green see yeah she's got a
problem why laughing yeah seriously
she's mad good I'd say I'd say that
she's probably did yeah not that she
means to do it she [ __ ] you'll often
laugh just ranaut you'll be doing a
really serious scene like what's
happened or you know
cousins in real trouble and she just
start laughing as far as other there's a
lot of products that get played as well
there's ed Clark's always good for an
elaborate one he's always got a prop or
something he's going to use I put I put
I got a license plate made with a very
rude word dog and I put on Chloe's car
and then she doing that was a given yeah
there's some Indians always up for for
prank as well but it's a who's a bit of
a dark horse is um Henry sit Henry
Simmons who plays Mac because you can't
tell when he's joking because he's such
a kind of like he's such a nice guy I'm
really quite earnest and everything and
then he just says something you're like
what like and it's normally quite crude
but he does it in a completely deadpan
he's good fun was it cheers thanks oh
Jesus Christ he didn't say you need to
get some cream for that
I've got down now my question is
basically um obviously I love other
series has done everything within humans
and how you've been integrating that
orbits the comic books into it for if
there was one character that you could
be that isn't yours who would you be in
the entire Marvel Universe entire Marvel
Universe
i Lance Han oh yeah Leo Leo Fitz
I'd probably I'd probably cook cousin
actually in control he wants to be in
control says a lot about his character
back on foot
who would I be tough question on the
show I wouldn't mind doing honestly
wouldn't mind a crack at Fitz that'd be
fun
are you familiar yes it is would you do
would you do a Scottish accent yeah well
I try try um oh shut up
Liza um I wouldn't mind I know I've done
this before
well I start to answer question and I
realized what I was about to say was
about self wouldn't might be one of the
girls to try no costumes have you if
neck was one of the girls for addy would
never get me the trailer that's your
question
I don't know I would not be any carts as
long as they were green yeah I hope you
shower before you go to bed snugs
otherwise your mum's gonna be very
annoyed of you again all that all over
the sheets
I hope you've not been touching any of
the walls as well when you've been
walking around there's a handprint on my
hotel door you're gonna get charged for
that I hope you didn't give your credit
card details
Dowler Nia how much how much makeup did
you use for that well just dive in a
pond but
to be honest we had to get up two hours
earlier than all of our friends and my
uber friends painted me and I just
sucked there like that and then they
would go away and do more of their
costumes and then they come back to me
like this and it was a very hard process
but it is great oh thank you do you feel
that the circumstances that your
characters come across do you think it
could possibly take place in in real
life maybe perhaps in a future life of
your own or something to that effect
well I mean it's quite an existential
question um I mean I think the cool
sometimes like the cool thing about
shield a lot of the characters in it is
that they're in the Marvel Universe with
all these supernatural elements and
things but they're normal people you
know so in that sense working for
they're normal people working for a very
secret government agency which I suppose
as possible yeah yeah um could I see how
many I I don't think I don't I don't
think so I reckon I'd probably just run
pretty quickly if any of that stuff
happened and also wouldn't be able to
keep a secret
if I was asked to join the team like
that I'd be be telling everyone and yes
so who knows I mean I did run in a bit
getting sort of my ass kicked by mex
wife I don't fancy that either I'll just
keep keep it low-key yeah yeah cheers
man thank you Thanks
hi it's a question directed it Ian
obviously from the first season imagines
of Sealand we seen you in you in Simmons
together pretty much all the time yeah
obviously seasons sorry season 2 you've
both been so right separated pre and
watched whole season how has that made
your characters grow yeah I think that
was kind of an important an important
fact for them to kind of they I think at
some point they had to separate and and
grow up and do kind of find different
things by themselves separately I think
obviously they were going through very
different things at the start of season
2
but they've got the kind of friendship I
think we're there there'll always be a
part of each other's life sort of thing
they'll ever be a moment no matter what
happens or how bad it gets that they
won't be able to work stuff out I think
they kind of they they work very well
together and that was really boring
answer
I wanted to find like a little joke at
the end like a little Limerick then like
like Nick does but could think important
so that we remember that's the end he
always does little limericks this neck
and yes that's that's my answer
it's great thank you thank you hey what
do you think is a funniest moment you've
ever had on the show oh I had well it
was funny for a lot of people watching I
was in on it but with my little
three-year-old nephew came they all came
to visitors in in LA and just as we're
about to do a take we were coming around
the corner it's the one where we're
about to go I think it's in the
second-to-last episode and me agent May
and Coulson come around the corridor
walk down and we're like right we're
going to go do this and kill these
people and all that stuff and we were
there and my little nephew was there and
Clark and what this came in it's giving
it so we came around the corner and they
all set up shooting it and we had my
little nephew in the scene so I'm hoping
they stick that in the DVD extras yeah
we we had one day actually quite
recently where Clark brought and AH you
ever seen those like little fart
machines yeah so we were doing during
the middle of a scene and it was only me
Clark and Chloe I think so it was me
cursing this guy they were in on it and
we said off right in the middle of the
scene and they blamed on Chloe and
everyone thought it was real one of the
greatest moments of my life actually
hi as you guys agree by the way if you
could choose any one thing to happen to
your character in the future what would
it be and why you go first
any one thing and I would like to have a
monkey can't believe dare to ask that
question yeah that's it clean assemble
and I would call it bonbon I was quite I
think I think it'd probably be like a
severe injury because I remember when
Chloe was you know all over in human
stuff and she basically spent a week
lying in that bed every day was shooting
and everyone stood around getting tired
and she's just lying back and I reckon
something like that would be all right
thank you hello
my question is pretty much just saying
like during a shoot like any episode
have you ever like stopped for a moment
and looked around and thought oh my god
is this real
like all this like fandom and people
scream my name like have you ever like
frozen blood no one screamed my name on
set while wish you yeah whole time it's
really cool we have we always have like
this huge big sets that we fell Marlin
huge special spare special effects and
stuff and and yeah coming like here
today and stuff you know it's weird
because when we're doing it's kind of
like a bit of a bubble and we don't know
if anyone watches it we don't know what
people like it and stuff so it's nice to
come and meet everyone and people are
fans of the show it was great to meet
them advance I definitely on my first
day on set was one of those moments
because it was a bit of a mad I
mentioned it earlier in the interview
thing like I was shooting something here
in fact right by here that while this
was on last year I was shooting
something here and I've wrapped on that
that evening flew to LA the next day was
driven from the airport to set I've
straightened a costume and makeup and
then was lying in a crashed car upside
down with a Xena the warrior princess
and and I was kind of like this is weird
like um so yeah definitely alien you do
got we were talking the other day that
you know you like in was saying you're
getting a bubble and you kind of get
used to it you get used to these insane
sets and the work that the set designers
do and or the art department and
everything the props guys is incredible
like the detail is is you know like
nothing I've ever seen before
and but you kind of get like anything
you kind of get used to it and then
every now and then you sit back and we
were same at this other day and you have
to kind of remember what how your 10
year old self would react to doing this
and it's nice when people come visit and
you can show them around the set and
then you kind of get reminded of that
first moment when you know when I saw
like the bus and stuff the first time it
was
it's mind-blowing what what they do you
know yeah yeah what's on your sign free
hugs oh yeah
I actually actually some are now making
a sign same five socks
I actually met her earlier and I only
saw the free bit and I saw the ug the
end s and I thought it said free drugs I
was like wow that's bold
fritzsche stupid as well giving them
away for free I can make up big make a
lot of money out last night you seen
Scarface just like to point out before
anybody starts scribbling free hugs
signs are you ask away well I kind of
wish I had got a sign like that I love
the show and as much as I respect Hunter
and it's much I love his character I
just got one question for you
he's a massive I'm sorry I'm sorry uh
but at the point where you discovered
that you would have to play fits with
this mental disability or his damage how
did you feel
and which season did you more enjoy
playing him when he was normal or after
he had had his accident that's a good
question um well for me when I came up
when they you know was their idea
obviously the writers and stuff and they
did a lot of research before I did and
then coincidentally that I'd actually
watched a documentary on em head trauma
before they told me so and then did my
own kind of research as well and I think
the main thing was is that it was uh
that it's that that something like that
is a very real thing that's happened to
a lot of people in a very real way so we
were just very mindful of being
respectful towards it and and hopefully
we were and yeah it was I suppose it was
a challenge so you know I suppose
playing the older vets which was a bit
more lighthearted was probably easier
but actually when you have a bit of a
child doing something it's bit of a
challenge when you come at the other
side it's actually more rewarding I
think that's you as novembri on either
lighting brilliantly as or in my opinion
yeah thanks
hi and one of my favorite things about
the show is the one-liners and they all
scripted or do you just kind of sneak
them in we get plenty from them we've
got some really good writers that have a
lot of fun but we do now and then don't
we we go we get a few as a few here and
there trying to think of it we did one
the other day with has it been on you
yeah yeah the whole thing's going on
yeah oh yeah so yeah talk about yourself
should we reenact it what was it I said
something like he interrupted no we
should check this thing and and I go
yeah you do know that I can finish my
own instances yeah we came up with that
I know you had to be there it was
funnier anything worked they kept it in
so yeah thanks
having seen all of season one and season
two in the relationships that develops
between yourself as Fitz and Simmons and
in season two between long between
hunter and Bobby
where do you hope we've locked with
hunter and Bobby where the relationship
will go and what sort of feelings are
going through Fitz's mind at the point
he discovers what has happened to
Simmons well
Jewish oh you told me before you want to
answer this one first
where would I like to see Bobby in
hunters they should go well I think the
most fun thing about it is that it's
this love/hate thing it's will they
won't they and they can never quite get
it together it's you know you can't live
with them can't live without them so I
imagine they're going to have fun with
that you know continually I would be
it'd be interesting to see if or not a
third part you got involved and if
hunter gets you know distracted by
someone or if Bobby does that that would
be quite fun I think it would drive
hunter
absolutely bonkers if she you know
hooked up with Fitz or something um she
would also tear them apart as well um so
yeah I think I think that'd be fun but
it'd be I think you never want it to be
too easy for them you know so I was
still thinking about Fitz and I yeah I
mean obviously of Simmons's I mean I
have absolutely no idea what's happened
to Simmons but I presumed that Fitz
would probably be prey heartbroke going
to be finds out she's gone missing or
doesn't know where she is
how do you think that could affect the
character they could play in
kryolan yeah pretty cry what more sad
and angry yeah I would affect him like
pretty dramatically I reckon I mean but
I don't know I don't know if she's you
know if she'll you know come back in ten
seconds or well I don't know where she's
going I don't know what's that you know
I have no idea so until then I can't
really think about it can't think too
far ahead
fair enough and leave but thank you have
a question for Ian but I just want to
say beforehand that you're the reason
that I watch the show in the first place
I've been a fan of yours for five years
I'm sorry we talked about this before
you will set down in you Alyssa why did
you invite your sister
I came for the Fitz I stayed for the
hunter it's okay but yeah in your big
inspiration to me as a writer Africa
thank you
so my my question for him is with the
time jump between the end of the first
series and the beginning of the second
there was a lot of Hospital scenes and
comas teens and all of that staff did
you want to do any of that because I
kind of remember you saying at some
point that there was a hospital to see
but it got cut out would you like to
have just gone straight into it series
two would you like to have done any of
the like the development stuff or were
you happy with it just being thrown in
no I think it was pretty I mean yeah we
did actually we formed a hospital scene
which would have been at the end of
season one where Betts wakes up but when
we were doing actually didn't really
work it was a bit rushed and it didn't
feel very right and actually with that
kind of head trauma a lot of people wake
up and they're not really there for the
first the first while so I don't really
know how much we could have really done
for it so doing it sex month so and then
the whole storyline that happens with
Simmons I think was played out a bit
more fully and we didn't have to kind of
waste time without that I feel like we
kind of hopefully got as much across as
we could with with having that that
break in between but it would have been
cool to do that and you what you're a
writer are you
I am yeah I'm studying a master's degree
at Yale just down the road in creative
writing oh very good thing you want to
write for Marvel then I would definitely
go where upper warden thank you yeah I
don't think hunters getting scenes is he
yeah
we yeah you could maybe write the pilot
for FETs and the monkey oh definitely
yeah thank you guys thank you just want
to say amazing show everyone agrees but
a Fitz and Simmons ever actually going
to go on a date because every time you
think it's going to happen like a
life-threatening situation comes up yeah
always bloody happens up and every time
you're gonna die in single yeah um yeah
I'm sure I mean that I've been pretty no
I mean that that's you're right
I have no I have no idea they're going
to play all that kind of as kind of that
will they won't they kind of thing they
obviously do have very strong feelings
for each other but you know aside from
all that I think the main thing is is
that they're very good friends I mean
it's kind of weird because me and
Elizabeth very early on we'd always
describe it as a brother-sister
relationship and then the writers were
like no you're gonna you got feelings
for each other so I don't know what that
says yeah I'm sure I mean eventually
they will do can you can you finish uh
yes yeah actually can I ask you a favor
yeah I brought my cousin for her
birthday and we queued but couldn't see
so could you wish you a happy birthday
oh ah happy birthday saying happy
birthday yeah
first one to every 100 another
what's her name what's her name quick
Lily Lily hi hello so if there's one
thing I've learned from watching agents
of shield it's not to trust any of you
now so far you two seem alright and if
your characters were going to explore
more of their dark side how do you think
that would play out yeah yeah he's not
he's a brave monkey I that's a good
question actually isn't it I suppose I
would maybe like create like an evil
robot that I would use to fight my
battles for me while I sat inside his
brain or something and moved about with
lots of like joysticks um
either that or offenses got quite a bad
temper sometimes maybe just I think you
started to see the dark side of Fitz
he's quite Moody's really you know he's
not happy with Ward and uh you know he's
had a few door run-ins with Simmons
something you do a lot crosswords mr.
Vader pin he's gonna be the big baddie
next season I reckon it's gonna be
running a Hydra it'll be like a really
weird like evil scientist all right what
would you do my butt isn't my my dark
side what would it be I just become an
alcoholic or something all right
a violent alcoholic hello hello Hey hi
Ian you shouldn't say you want to look
like Brett because you're gorgeous
oh and everyone agree with me come on oh
thanks that's just the start I just want
I more and more want his body No
have you seen his buddy I don't care I
have the body of a 14 year old no jokes
all right when I go on the beach and
take my top off people ask me I lost my
mom and dad I don't know I get yeah I
saw it yeah but thank you um so question
what do you guys fangirl and fanboy
about on set like what are the things
that you guys are obsessed with
especially the past year um I like we
have the Quinjet you know the yeah the
pictures which were using which they use
which is actually when they used in you
know Captain America when they all jump
out at the back of the start when they
will jump at the back the little plane
skydive down that we use that actually
won in the show no that's quick and he's
got runs on it like monkey bars so we're
always on em in fact I injured myself
swinging across him but we were like
doing like matrix poses like in the air
like you know holding onto these monkey
bars that's quite fun and and I got a
football to play with in one of the
scenes and that kept that kept me I'm
occupied for the whole afternoon
I also nearly smashed a light bulb and
you know knocked over various things
booting it around the bus so yeah the
football that's really sad and it out of
all those things you guys just a ball
that's not a lot bouncing a ball yeah
there was like when we first started
they have these like amazing I had these
drones that went about everywhere we
were filming like CGI and a green screen
there was his huge bus set and then
someone Damien Elizabeth were sitting
down and someone handed us a bottle of
water and I had a shield logo on and we
were like what that you know it's like
most exciting thing ever simple
pleasures
thank you thank you guys you busy
texting yeah
sorry are we keeping you his phone just
well you can take the call when you
first started did you what we did what
heroes were you looking forward to see
like which heroes did you want to be in
the series with you Fitz
here's my hero come on I I was always
like looking for like I didn't cook I
don't know what I remember then I don't
know what the name of him was at the
time but it was always looking for this
kind of just like a character like an
English guy he was quite funny who you
know likes a good beer and like you know
could handle himself you know well I
just kind of and and you know and I'm
still looking for that he's your
favorite character here's you watch what
you say
all right thought I reckon I could take
him yeah he's nothing without that
hammer yeah thank you cheers mate hello
doing that dance or pretty good number
right um by the way if anyone does have
that video could I keep it online I want
to show a friend once was this our dance
off earlier on on the stage against
another star Lord somewhere over there
oh wait did you get paid for that oh no
well that gave us freebies that was nice
okay right um my shows you dance uh has
anyone got it so I can put it online
no you can just do it now I want to see
it live yes
right my question is to you Nick right
so being on Trollied and then changing
to marvel's agents of shield how much of
a difference was it in it how much of a
difference was it well it was quite a
long there was quite a long gap between
you two like I think I left that showed
I could over well over a year beforehand
so I kind of I I did do other stuff if I
didn't literally just put down my apron
and then put on a cape um but yeah I
mean is it's weird really because it's
kind of like we were saying earlier like
um the job really once you kind of
there's amazing sets and you know the
budgets are huge and everything and then
once the cameras on it's the same job
really you're still trying to make sense
of a script to make it you know you know
kind of acknowledge it do justice this
script and kind of acknowledge all the
kind of beats and the character moments
in it so it's kind of you know weirdly
you know doing something like Trollied
or any of the other jobs you do it's
kind of once the cameras roll in it it's
the same job do you know what I mean
but but as far as like the physical side
to it and everything that's obviously
had a lot there and there wasn't that
many stunts or guns and I'm Trollied but
it'd be fun if there was for those who
don't know it's like a supermarket
comedy I did so um yeah in fact merging
those two together would be like a ages
to shield meets Trollied yeah that'd be
fun agents of aster thank you yeah
cheers man so I was wondering do you do
like any preparation to get yourself
into character like and once you're in
character do you do method acting and
stay in character
I don't know honest answer is is no
don't it don't do any method acting as
such um I think that we we from we film
it for like nine months of the year so
actually by the time we get into like
Episode four it's pretty you just get
into the swing of dinner to sing with
learning lines actually really kind of I
can look at scene a couple of times and
I know
yes you do kind of that's really true
because you can sometimes I'll find
myself when you're shooting something
and after the first few weeks and you're
going that was doing loads of homework
before now I'm not and you start to feel
really guilty because you feel like
you're not good at doing the work but
you've you've kind of already done it
and you do all that work of you know
research the character ideas from the
scripts and stuff and then you kind of
let that go and just get on with it but
I think what the difference is with this
as well in America because there's such
long seasons you get scripts as you go
so the character develops and certainly
with Hunter I know that they they had an
idea of what they wanted but they kind
of develop it as they're writing it
whereas in the UK and if you're doing a
film as well you get the whole thing in
one go so you can really kind of
concentrate on it and and all that
character work but with this it's more
of a kind of ongoing organic thing
really but as far as like the method
side of it no because I think if you're
doing like nine months the year I'd be
an alcoholic laughs yeah so yeah it's
kind of you do the work early on and
then you can play around really yeah
Thank You Cheers
hi if you could choose any way for your
character to die what would it be a long
slow painful death I reckon spread out
over a few episodes yeah you just hear
you in the background like during the
season
oh um that's a good question I don't
want to say anything too good because
then they might just do it
ha ha ha do you think for Fitz I reckon
he'd have to die of a broken heart
what yeah as monkey dive that's all I
meant
yeah well there'd be like room and
Juliet I'd like the point I'd like the
poison off his lips ah thank you thank
you he's really taking this Youth isn't
quite forwarding I'm sorry I'm sorry
hey man hello so some of the things I
like most about the show when in amongst
all of the action and stuff he gets like
really silly lighthearted moments like
um one I particularly like with some
Coulson was making a cup of coffee and
comes across a grumpy cat mug I was
wandering sort of how much of that is
plans or do they have their scenes where
they say make this light-hearted do
something funny there's a bit both
really and things like grumpy cat was we
ordered that mug in for sure but yeah
there will be stuff where you you know
we get the scripture a few days before
we start shooting and we do like a
read-through and stuff so we have time
to kind of discuss some things and come
up with ideas and they definitely you
know if you like I don't think the final
episodes been on here yet has it has it
it's not as I'm not going to get I can
um yeah there's some stuff that you can
add in and deal that kind of stuff there
they're quite open to that and then they
can kind of decide what they want to
keep in the Edit I suppose um yeah it's
pretty natural so I was loaned out for
set things I was just think about the
fact that
the last episode hasn't been analyzed
again have I given anything away live
map so remind what the question was how
much when there was silly funny much
yeah how much of those are plans or they
just say I think something silly I mean
no I agree view I think that like one of
the great things about the show is is
that irreverence and the fact is quite
tongue-in-cheek at times and it gives it
a heart and makes it quite real because
life like life's like that you know it's
not all serious and doom and gloom no
matter what situation you're in you know
but we just have a great team of right
is that you know considering it's a you
know a comic book show a sci-fi show or
whatever you want to call it that the
fact that we've got comic writers on the
show really a lot of the time so we're
fortunate that we you know I'd love to
take credit for all the the funny lines
but I'd say large this is the right is
and we just get to then play around with
it you know thank all cheers man
hi guys too much so obviously agents of
shield is always like this little family
and this season you've had Nick and a
lot of other actors come in how has it
been for each of you to jut for Ian to
have people new people join this little
family and for you Nick to join this I
love it it's the best when you people
come in especially when you get on with
them there hasn't been anyone actually
it's come in that I don't think people
haven't got go I'm with but we yeah the
additions this year have just been
perfect really good Nick got Henry you
please mark
we've got Adrian who plays mockingbirds
and yeah it's been great
okay yeah I hate I mean we all get on
very very well which is really lucky I
hate to think what would be like if we
hated each other do not mean or or if
someone just was like a huge diva yeah I
mean it's the show I know everyone says
about shows and almost like a big family
it's all loving all that bit in LA where
we shoot and you obviously meet a lot of
people industry people there and people
that work on crews and when it will you
meet and they know that you on the show
that what I've heard that you know the
atmosphere on set is amazing and you
know it does have a reputation for being
a really kind of friendly atmosphere and
very
kind of you know cohesive team and for
me I mean I'd be lying if I said it
wasn't you know apprehensive about it
because you know I've never joined the
show before I've never you know part way
through kind of thing but everyone just
makes you feel at home everybody's
really down-to-earth and normal and you
know feel fortunate like you know having
another brick there is kind of similar
interests and stuff we hang out all the
time and you know it everyone's just
cool they're just just nice people
it's always nice working with nice
people you know go thank you thanks see
ya you're right guys hello I just fought
in Oakland spheal Carlson's back alive
do you think he should go straight into
New Avengers film within at war or do
you think Linda's not gonna put him in
it I think it should I would love to see
a minute I thought yeah I thought he was
gonna be the one just yeah we all
thought that he was keeping it a secret
he was gonna crop up in in the latest
one but alas he couldn't be it doesn't
yeah I don't know I mean I suppose
Avengers dawn the trouble is a lot of
time as well because we like the
Avengers of shoot and while we were
shooting so it's quite tricky
practically for them to be able to go
right we'll take you out of this because
it's pretty full on schedule you know
you don't get a great deal of time to
yeah especially Clark at least course
yeah yeah he's and he's also got all
that technical jargon to learn so you
know he's got his work cut out but I
great to see him and I would like to see
minute yeah I'm sure everyone else would
right I think I think how great a job he
did in the film is kind of the reason
why shield exists in the first place
isn't it yeah the popularity of his
character kind of that's what shield was
born out of you know so yeah hopefully
I'll be back thank you thank you says
here and this lady here now has two
sitting distinct honor of be the final
question make it good and it's really
frivolous I'm really sorry
um there's quite a bit of significance
with Fitz and his favorite sandwich I
just want it for both of you what your
actual favorite sandwiches would be
actually there's this place near where I
stay in America it's called potato chips
that does the best meatball sandwich
you've ever had
that's what sweet meatball sandwich
mines can be really lame cuz I'm I'm a
vegan so it's just like just some bread
with the loader like vegetables in it
what's your one what's your one what
probably steak and blue cheese you
murderer sounds nice
thank you yeah Cheers well ladies and
gentlemen that is all the time we have
for please give it up for agency cheer
back
you